joy behar on the view says
this woman is
perfect
here you have a woman
katanji who reminded me of obama a
little bit because he he was also
perfect he had nothing wrong going on so
what you have here are 50 senators who
are going to vote against
this woman who is above reproach
and the first black woman in that
position that is going to be on their
record and that's why they're asking
these dumb questions so that they can
have something to bring back to their
constituency when they go home and say
well look at you know she doesn't
believe that babies are racist or
whatever the hell they were talking
about who even knows what they're
talking about but they need something
because it's an embarrassment to the
country to vote against a woman of this
caliber
she's perfect she reminds me of obama
she reminds you of a
she reminds you of obama because she's
black that's what you're saying and she
she brings it back to race at the end
too so first she goes this woman she
reminds me of obama and then i think joy
behar realized that she was making a
comment that was extremely condescending
and obviously very racial so she said
because they're both perfect
but then she brings it back to race at
the end right she says and black people
need to be perfect for these awful
racist republicans to get by that's
preposterous
a white person
in katanji
jackson's with with her record with her
background would not be she wouldn't
even be nominated for the supreme court
right now we know that because joe biden
explicitly said i'm only going to pick a
black woman
we're going to get a diversity hire
there might be qualified white guys or
asian guys or hispanic guys or other
women but only a black woman
she says well you're at a disadvantage
if you're black no not according to
not according to joe biden not according
to affirmative action not according to
the law
so no and she because she's perfect well
let's see she can't define what life is
she's defending pedophiles and she
doesn't know what a woman is she herself
a woman doesn't sound all that perfect
to me just like obama he was perfect
barack obama is the chicago machine
politician
one of the more corrupt presidents not
the most corrupt one of the more corrupt
presidents we've had in recent memory
but he's perfect
no no drama obama no scandals on his
watch like the irs targeting scandal
channeling the federal bureaucracy
against your political opponents like
the fast and furious scandal like the
benghazi skin like no he's perfect
forget about it hear no evil see no evil
no way
the whole motivation
the whole motivation here to support
this woman
is for her race
and for her sex for sex that she cannot
even define right now go to
tessamayas.com promo code michael what
if
eating healthy also tasted great
these seem like they are completely in
conflict with each other but they're not
thanks to tessa mays tessa mays found a
way with their award-winning ranch
dressings and vinaigrettes to make
healthy food taste great tessamese is an
american-made company started by three
brothers with a dream to share their
mom's recipes with the world tessame's
tastes great they put flavor and quality
above all else and because of that they
quickly became the number one organic
dressing brand in the country all of
their products are manufactured here in
the us of a which i love and they have a
wide variety of anything you want kosher
whole30 keto products what you you want
it they'll have it for you whether
you're in the mood for a creamy avocado
ranch or a light refreshing lemon garlic
dressing and marinade there is a
testament product for every occasion
kids parents and grandparents can all
agree on one thing tessam's dressings
are good on everything dipping wings
pizza pouring it on a salad sesames
makes every meal better these guys are
the embodiment of the american dream
they're bringing manufacturing back to
america their products most importantly
taste great go to tessamays.com use
promo code michael for 15 off their
their terrific product
t e s s e
m a e s dot com promo code michael
i'm glad you like that clip now if you
want more clips you got to ring the bell
subscribe to the michael knowles show
head on over to apple podcast spotify
stitch or google play wherever you get
your podcasts maybe leave a five star
review and go check out my three part
docu series it is blowing up on the
daily wire i think it might be the most
popular
product we've ever put out on the daily
wire for the daily wire audience it's
called fouchy unmasked it's the behind
the scenes true story you've never seen
this before of dr fauci's rise to power
so go check that out we'll see you next
time
[Music]
[Music]